nous allons vous conter l'histoire les
aventures des aventures nous allons vous
conter l'espoir les aventures
la peau
les renards sont en pleine phase 1
des envies
je trouve yeux le
naturel eux
[Musique]
[Rires]
où
oh
[Rires]
où
on
[Musique]
oui mon père je vous apporte des
nouvelles
ouvrez mois
mais moi d'où je vous dis ce sont
d'excellentes nouvelles du mois ils ont
gravement à je vous avais pris pour un
voleur
attendez au moins que les frères soit
levé de table
il aurait il des moines chez vous
bien sûr ce sont ceux de l'abbaye de
dire on
ils m'ont fait la grâce de me recevoir
dans leur ordre ouvre moi
je voulais avoir de tes nouvelles j'ai
grand fleuve du ces
serait ce de l'avion que vous préparez
ainsi que non la religion interdit
ce sont de gros et gras poisson ce sera
nouveau pour moi mais veux tu as accordé
le gîte pour cette nuit mais la has pour
rentrer il faut être ordonné moine
vous n'êtes pas passer notre chemin
[Musique]
[Rires]
donne moi donc un meursault beauté bien
sûr voilà de la part de nos frères dans
l'espoir que vous serez bientôt d'un
autre excellent qu'elle dit je me sens
tout près de la conversion
puis-je en avoir un souvent il ne tient
qu'à vous quand vous aurez passé la robe
vous en aurez autant que voudrait alors
d'accord fais-moi raser le crâne
[Musique]
passez votre tête par le pertuis que je
vous fasse votre couronne
oh
oh oh oh no oh ouais
[Musique]
ronald à
oh